wir machen uns auf die Suche nach den
drei besten digitalvisionären einer
davon beschäftigt sich mit künstlicher
Intelligenz kurz KI und wie sie den
Arbeitsalltag in Fabriken verändern kann
unser Platz 3
viel von dem was heute passiert liegt
daran dass wir alle die wir heute KI
machen in den 90ern dieser Science
Fiction Bücher gelesen haben
und wir sehen dass an anderen Stellen
das wird immer gesagt
nee die waren 25 Jahre vorher ein Star
Trek wir bauen diese Zukunft halt wenn
wir so attraktiv fahren
guten Morgen
[Musik]
mein Name ist ich bin einer der Gründer
und einer der Geschäftsführer der Markus
Industries GmbH wir bauen ein Produkt
das mit KI Industrie Roboter steuert und
den möglichst Dinge zu tun die Menschen
nicht mehr machen wollen
ronny hat eine künstliche Intelligenz
entwickelt die Roboter in Echtzeit
reagieren lässt eine Weltneuheit die vor
ein paar Jahren und denkbar war
[Musik]
so hier mitten in Berlin Kreuzberg ist
der Ort wo Roboterarme zum Leben werden
[Musik]
hallo
begonnen hat Ronny mit vier Freunden
inzwischen beschäftigt das Unternehmen
über 70 Leute und für uns geht es jetzt
ab ins Bett
ihr müsst nämlich wissen das ist hier
gar kein Fahrstuhl sondern eine
Zeitreise Maschine und jetzt geht's ab
in die Zukunft
die Zeitmaschine bringt uns in den
Keller hier werden Roboterarme für ihren
späteren Einsatz vorbereitet
schon sehr komplex aus es ist komplex
tatsächlich die Technologien der Zukunft
zu entwerfen ist für Ronny ein
Kindheitstraum er entscheidet sich nach
dem Abitur Informatik und Philosophie in
Berlin zu studieren eine eher
ungewöhnliche Fächerkombi
[Musik]
ich habe relativ schnell gemerkt dass es
so ein paar wenige Felder gibt wo sich
diese beiden Fächer überschneiden und
die Frage was ist eigentlich Intelligenz
und wie funktioniert denken bei Menschen
aber auch in der hypothetischen Welt bei
Maschinen ist einer dieser
Berührungspunkte sein Interesse an KI
wächst Ronny findet an der Uni
Gleichgesinnte gemeinsam beginnen Sie
die ersten Versuche eine KI zu
programmieren es sind Spielereien denn
Anfang der 2000er steckt die Forschung
noch in den Kinderschuhen
ganz im Gegensatz zu heute in Ronnys
Firma lernen Roboter mit Hilfe
künstlicher Intelligenz selbstständig zu
reagieren
und so diese arme ich meine das kennt
man schon so ein bisschen aus der
Autoindustrie was ist jetzt hier
besonders was ist neu genau
typischerweise machen diese Roboter
einfach stumpf immer die gleiche Sache
festes Programm fahren das durch hier
ist neu dass wir auf die Welt reagieren
ich könnte jetzt hier rein fassen
während der Roboter diese Kontaktierung
probiert und dann kommt der einfach mit
also das bedeutet dann denkt der Roboter
mit
sogar wenn das Bauteil sich begrüßt also
wir sagen Handarbeit Koordination
die Augen hier sind kleine Kameras mit
Hilfe der KI trainiert der Roboter die
richtige Bewegung und das darf ich
später sogar selber mal testen
inzwischen wohnt Ronny in Hessen er ist
ein Macher probiert gern Neues aus nach
dem Studium gründet er mit seinen
Kommilitonen ein Unternehmen mit KI hat
das erstmal gar nichts zu tun sie
bringen eBooks auf den Markt doch werden
von Amazon um Längen überholt das
Unternehmen scheitert
ab 2010 arbeitet Ronny als Berater für
eine Bank doch der Job langweilt ihn
sein Interesse an der KI-Forschung
bleibt
[Musik]
immer machen wollte schlimmer als das
mit der Beratung verdiente Geld
verlieren kann mir jetzt nicht passieren
und das wäre okay für mich ich probiere
es jetzt so dann habe ich alle angerufen
und manche musste ich ein bisschen mehr
überzeugen und manche waren schneller
dabei
die Freunde aus der Uni sind wieder
vereint nur was für eine KI wollen Sie
bauen die Gruppe kommt mit Fabriken ins
Gespräch es wird ihnen von eintönigen
oder sogar gefährlichen Jobs in den
Werken berichtet
und man will das wirklich keine Menschen
antun diese Arbeit zu machen und es wäre
so gut wenn das mit Roboter ginge aber
es geht eben mit einer fixen
Programmierung nicht man braucht die KI
so eine Anwendung zu machen das war eine
gute Kombination
die Idee ist geboren und so beginnt 2014
das Team um Ronny mit der Forschung an
ihrer k.i dank der Unterstützung von
investorengeldern dürften sie fünf Jahre
an der Software
2019 ist die ki-marktauglich und ich
probiere es aus dafür haben wir uns ein
Spielerei ausgedacht der Roboter soll
eine Dose öffnen die Schwierigkeit er
muss sie finden und erkennen egal wo auf
den Tisch sie steht
Peter Peter zeigt dir wie wir so ein
Roboter trainieren und seine Aufgabe zu
machen also deine und die Aufgabe von
unserem System hier ist diese Position
zu finden
fährt dann geht die Dose auf und wenn
sie zischt
haben soll
trainieren das fängt so an dass hier man
der Roboter an dieser graue Teil anfasst
und
so in ein Tornado Bewegung okay um herum
zeigt mit Hilfe der angebrachten Kameras
nimmt das System die möglichen
Positionen der Dose auf so wird sein
Wissen trainiert später kann der Roboter
die Kameras dann wie Augen benutzen und
erkennt die Dose okay okay so mein
lieber Tag meine Arbeit jetzt zusammen
und ich zeig dir mal das ist hier deine
Dose
kannst du von hier aufmachen
es gar nicht so er ist ein bisschen
störrisch
und so sieht es von oben aus
das war's das war das hat er jetzt
aufgezeichnet und sich gemerkt und das
machst du jetzt so ungefähr für so eine
Anwendung 20 30 mal damit er immer jedes
millimeterchen jede Konstellation mal
gesehen hat
[Musik]
die Informationen werden gespeichert so
dass die KI darauf zugreifen kann was KI
kann ist erstaunlich aber auch
beängstigend immerhin hat jede achte
Erwerbstätige Person Angst durch
künstliche Intelligenz den Job zu
verlieren
wie würdest du denn so deine Mission
beschreiben mit dem Produkt was du
entwickelt hast wir machen den Kram den
die Leute täglich benutzen und wir
machen den so günstig und wir machen den
so gut und wir machen den so sicher dass
alle ein gutes Leben haben so also das
ist das was aufregen ist an dieser
ganzen Welt ein gutes Leben auch weil
Automatisierung tatsächlich
Arbeitsplätze schafft zwar sollen einer
Studie zufolge bis 2035 0,8 Millionen
Jobs aufgrund von Automatisierung
wegfallen doch es entstehen auch etwa
2,1 Millionen Jobs unter anderem durch
den daraus resultierenden globalen
Wettbewerbsvorteil
peter hat die 30 Trainingseinheiten
übernommen und ich hoffe endlich etwas
zu trinken zu bekommen
[Musik]
krass er weiß einfach
wo ich hingehe und er will schon ganz
übereifrig an den nupsi
anstoßen oder gut gemacht
ronny hat sich mit der Entwicklung
seiner KI einen Traum erfüllt und auch
privat läuft es gut er ist gerade Vater
geworden und hat für seine kleine
Familie ein sanierungsbedürftiges Haus
gekauft hier schreinert er nun als
Ausgleich zum programmieren
für mich ist das machen das eigentlich
Wichtige also ob das jetzt Software ist
oder ein Regal finde ich gar nicht so
wichtig aber dieses man nimmt sich was
vor und dann legt man sich so einen Plan
zurecht und dann am Ende macht man viel
falsch und kauft das Material zweimal
und hat nicht das richtige Werkzeug
wirst du noch ein Problem noch ein
Problem und dann ist das Ding da und
schön
das ist toll also das ist einfach und
also vieles von dem was ich mache
beruflich und privat hat diese Struktur
ich fahre mit Ronny zu einem Betrieb in
Berlin hier wird unter anderem Stahl
gehärtet zum Beispiel für Messerklingen
Geschäftsführer Kai Lemke setzt dabei
die ki-software von Minecraft
ja das ist unser kleines elektronisches
Helferlein
[Musik]
warum ist es denn für Ihr Unternehmen
jetzt wichtig genau diese Art von
Technik also in Berlin sagt man immer so
das passt immer ganz gut immer ist was
irgendwas ist immer und jetzt wollen die
anders und jetzt dreht sich das Teil und
jetzt müssten wir es umprogrammieren und
früher waren das ein großer Aufwand und
was uns an diesem Lösungen hier und
speziell an der gefällt ist dass das
sehr flexibel ist und dass man sehr oben
meint ist also offen und sagt da könnt
ihr auch selber und ihr könnt auch viele
Dinge selber machen und wie siehst du
denn diese Geschichte mit den
Arbeitsplätzen es ist ja schon
auch im allgemeinen ist das eine
Transformation und die läuft auch schon
sehr lange die größte Revolution jetzt
in den letzten Jahrzehnten war ja gar
nicht in die Roboter oder KI sondern
Computer also gibt keine Reise mehr die
Leute machen das anderes die sind nicht
alle arbeitslos sondern wir ziehen
weitermachen höherwertige Arbeit haben
erfüllter Leben und günstige Produkte
hochwertige Arbeit und erfülltes Leben
ich nehme Dich beim Wort Ronny und hoffe
dass der Einsatz von künstlicher
Intelligenz in der Arbeitswelt für uns
alle etwas Gutes bringen wird
mein letzter Krankenhausaufenthalt ist
über ein Jahr her und man glaubt es kaum
bei der Visite sind die Ärztin mit
Klemmbrett Stift und Zettel unterwegs
gewesen gibt es da nicht längst
Alternativen im Zeitalter von Tablet und
Co
im verstaubten Gesundheitssystem ist es
längszeit für den digitalen Wandel das
findet auch unsere Visionärin auf Platz
2 über 30% verbringen Pflegekräfte und
Ärzte mit Dokumentation und das muss weg
die sind nicht angetreten die wollen
Menschen gesund machen und das können
wir mit Digitalisierung
[Musik]
mein Name ist Leiner Wale und ich
unterstütze Gesundheitseinrichtungen bei
der Digitalisierung ihrer Prozesse wir
stellen die Patienten in den Mittelpunkt
und gehen wirklich entlang seiner
Bedürfnisse
Laila Wale ist studierte
medizintechnikerin hinter dir liegt ein
langer Weg der noch längst nicht beendet
ist denn die knapp 1900 Krankenhäuser in
Deutschland sind weit entfernt von der
Digitalisierung
auf einer internationalen
digitalisierungsskala erreicht
Deutschland gerade mal ein Wert von 2,3
von möglichen sieben
innerhalb der EU wird im Durchschnitt
immerhin eine 3,6 erreicht
die USA haben sogar ein
Durchschnittswert von 5,3
es ist 7 Uhr morgens ich reise heute
morgen in die Zukunft denn das hier ist
eins der ersten digitalisierten
Krankenhäuser Deutschlands und was das
für die Patientin und das Personal
bedeutet schauen wir uns jetzt an
[Musik]
das Krankenhaus St adolf-Stift in
Reinbek bei Hamburg es ist das
Pilotprojekt von Laila Wale und sie
nimmt mich heute mit in den digitalen
Krankenhausalltag
[Musik]
guten Morgen
wir legen gleich los
der Gefäßmedizin Frau Dr Sommerfeld hast
du schon auf uns okay
hallo guten Morgen guten Morgen Frau Dr
Sommerfeld
hier wird sich über die Patienten
ausgetauscht doch statt mit Papierakten
wird die Besprechung anhand digitaler
Daten geführt und darauf haben alle auf
ihren Tablets rund um die Uhr Zugriff
kam zu glauben aber ja das ist eine
Seltenheit in deutschen Krankenhäusern
da stehen letztendlich alle
Informationen die für uns wichtig sind
was müssen wir bei dem Patienten
beachten wann wird der entlassen
welche Dinge sind sozusagen die
Mitarbeitern vielleicht beim Durchgucken
von Befunden aufgefallen worüber müssen
wir reden wie muss ich mir dann
vorstellen wie es vorher war bevor ihr
das Programm hattet so wie wir groß
geworden sind jeder hatte einen Zettel
in seiner Tasche aber viel Zettel oder
hatte sozusagen so ein Schreibblock auf
dem visitenwagen liegen wo wir eine
To-Do-Liste per Hand geschrieben haben
in vielen Kliniken ist das bis heute
tatsächlich Alltag Leila Wale ist selbst
keine Ärztin aber eine wahre
krankenhauskennerin
wir sehen uns gleich oben
[Musik]
ich habe in meinem Leben ungefähr 1000
Krankenhäuser schon von innen gesehen
Gott sei Dank meistens beruflich ihre
ersten Erfahrungen macht sie bereits als
junges Mädchen meine Mutter ist
chronisch krank gewesen und zwar auch
mit häufigen Krankenhausaufenthalten
verbunden das heißt ich habe eigentlich
die Hälfte meiner Kindheit im
Krankenhaus verbracht obwohl ich gar
nicht krank war und habe dort schon
mitbekommen wie teilweise unabgestimmt
Diagnosen erstellt worden nach dem
Abitur studiert sie dann Medizintechnik
und arbeitet bei einem
prothesenhersteller dann bekommt leider
zwei Kinder für ihren bisherigen Job ist
sie viel unterwegs mit der Familie
schlecht vereinbar sie wechselt die
Arbeit und landet im Krankenhaus als
Vermittlerin zwischen IT und dem
Personal
das war ehrlicherweise ein ziemlicher
Kulturschock ich habe vorher in einer
amerikanischen Firma gearbeitet die in
eine entsprechende Dynamik hat so wie
man sie kennt und ein deutsches
Krankenhaus ist jetzt nicht unbedingt
die dynamischen Einrichtung
2017 wird leider vom Krankenhaus Reinbek
engagiert um dort den digitalen Wandel
zu begleiten Tablets gehören hier
inzwischen zum Alltag auf diesen kleinen
iPad sind die gleichen Informationen wie
auf dem großen Monitor das heißt wenn
wir Visite machen wird der Patient von
den Kollegen letztendlich hier in diesem
Programm aufgerufen und wir haben alle
Informationen
guten Morgen
Herrn Benner wurde ein Tumor am Bein
entfernt und die Wunde schmerzt ein
bisschen mehr Schmerzmittel
haben
aber da kann mir nicht liegen
okay wir sprechen über die
Digitalisierung im Krankenhaus mit den
iPads und das ist alles die Abläufe
verbessert kriegen sie davon als Patient
auch nicht
kann mir gute Rede früher war so viel
die machen hier die Patient hatte die
ganze so sagen wir die Besuch gekommen
erste da war so viel Papierkram und
jetzt fällt mir gerade das wirklich das
kommt jetzt alles automatisch auch noch
gut ist dass wir halt zum Beispiel
gerade in der Visite der Patient
Schmerzen hatte und wie das dann direkt
digital anordnen können dann müssen wir
nicht erst die Visite abwarten sondern
können das direkt schon hier im System
eingeben die bekommen das vorne mit und
das kann dann laufen und das ist ja
alles wertvolle Zeit die ihr braucht ja
für andere Dinge
und zwar zeigt die so für den Patienten
genutzt werden kann in Echtzeit landet
die Info direkt bei den Pflegekräften
genau also hier kann ich eben sehen in
dem roten Feld das ist Anordnung gibt
bei Männer und hier sehe ich dass das
Medikament Oxycodon akut bei Bedarf
angeordnet wurde und ähm das kann ich
jetzt quasi abhaken normalerweise gehen
Infos erst nach der Visite an die
Pflegerinnen und Pfleger das kann schon
mal zwei Stunden dauern
ich weiß ja nicht wie es euch geht aber
ich denke die ganze Zeit es kann doch
nicht sein dass das die Neuigkeiten sind
aber offenbar ist es im Gesundheitswesen
so verstaubt dass das die Neuigkeiten
sind aber ich muss es mir leider jetzt
sprechen
es ging hier heute um Faxe es ging um
Zettelwirtschaft um Mappen um der eine
weiß noch nicht was der andere Briefe
wie kann das sein dass es so im so ein
bisschen schlafen ist wir haben ganz
ganz viele Menschen die irgendwann mal
krank werden können aber die die krank
sind die haben meistens andere Sorgen
als ich darüber Gedanken zu machen wie
kann ich jetzt das Gesundheitswesen
besser machen also es muss eigentlich
von denjenigen kommen die eben
tagtäglich damit arbeiten und die Lobby
ist natürlich nicht groß wenn man das
vergleicht mit Märkten
konsumentenmärkten
Nahrungsmittelindustrie Autoindustrie
und so weiter dann haben einfach viel
viel mehr Menschen das Bedürfnis nach
einem neuen Auto als sich jetzt darum zu
kümmern so blöd das klingt wie es
eigentlich Ihre Gesundheit geht das
interessiert einen dann in dem Moment wo
man krank ist
leider beweist Teamgeist und setzt sich
für andere ein und das auch in ihrem
Privatleben denn sie spielt
leidenschaftlich
ihre Genauigkeit und ihre
Standhaftigkeit werden von ihren
Teamkolleginnen geschätzt
und ihre Hartnäckigkeit hat sie im
Krankenhaus Reinbek den digitalen
medikationsplan eingeführt und der
rettet Leben
wir haben hier eine Anzeige welche
Medikamente können vielleicht auch in
Kombination Probleme bereiten oder
welche Medikamente muss ich in der Dosis
reduzieren weil der Patient bestimmte
Vorerkrankungen hat also wenn ich jetzt
so sehe was der hier alles kriegt das
ist ja schon wichtig dass ich da auch
nichts irgendwie in die Quere kommt ne
absolut ja das muss man sich eben
vorstellen wenn man so ein Programm
nicht hat was einem daran erinnert was
ihm früher so es gab ein großes großes
dickes Buch das nennt sich rote Liste
das ist wie so ein Telefonbuch gewesen
mit ganz dünnen Seiten und da musste man
das Medikamenten raussuchen oder die
verschiedenen Medikamenten jetzt musst
du nicht vorstellen 10 15 Medikamente
sind keine Seltenheit gucke ich alles
nach guck mir die Nebenwirkungen an guck
mir die Unverträglichkeiten an was das
eben auch für Zeit kostet und es kostet
sogar Menschenleben denn weltweit
sterben etwa jede Minute fünf Personen
aufgrund falscher Medikamentenvergabe
somit könnten allein in Deutschland
durch digital unterstützt der
Arzneimitteltherapie jährlich zwischen
65000 bis 70 000 Todesfälle verhindert
werden die Digitalisierung im
Krankenhaus ist ein Thema was uns sicher
alle mal betrifft und dann ist es doch
gut zu wissen dass dadurch mehr Zeit
bleibt für den Menschen und die wirklich
wichtigen Dinge
es gibt ja so Sachen auf die hat man
einfach gar keine Lust wie zum Beispiel
neuen Ausweis beantragen oder das Auto
anmelden warum weil man meistens zum Amt
rennen muss und alle möglichen Dokumente
zusammentragen muss also von
Digitalisierung ist die deutsche
Bürokratie echt meilenweit entfernt
wie man sich Zeit und Nervens sparen
kann wenn man Bürokratie online erledigt
das zeigt uns das kleine Land Island
unser Platz 1
[Musik]
kann mich nicht daran erinnern wann ich
das letzte Mal auf Papier unterschreiben
musste oder ein Rezept auf Papier vom
Arzt bekommen habe keine Ahnung das ist
vielleicht 20 Jahre her
mein Name ist geil ich bin Lena weg und
meine berufliche Karriere habe ich damit
verbracht Estland zu digitalisieren
das Land im östlichen Norden von Europa
hat insgesamt 1,3 Millionen Einwohner
und gilt als Vorbild der digitalen
Gesellschaft ich bin jetzt in Italien
und hier werden sogar die Drinks von
Robotern gemischt und serviert ich finde
das richtig krass ich schau mal ganz
kurz ob das auch hinbekommen hat
ja schmeckt gut also ich bin echt
gespannt darauf was mich in dieser Stadt
noch so erwartet
bei es tun ja dem Projekt der ethnischen
Regierung das für die Digitalisierung
der öffentlichen Dienstleistungen
zuständig ist treffe ich Linder weg
du bist also Mister Internet man hat mir
erzählt dass man dich hier so nennt
warum
vielleicht weil ich in vielen
digitalisierungsprozessen in Island
beteiligt war
ich habe von Anfang an den
Premierminister beraten und bin immer
noch Teil der Regierung und berate noch
heute den zuständigen Minister für
Digitalisierung
1991 seine Unabhängigkeit erklärte war
Lena Anfang 20 und das World Wide Web
gerade erst erfunden er sah darin eine
Chance für den Neuanfang seines Landes
und überzeugte den Premierminister von
seinen Ideen
25 Jahren der jüngste Berater der
Regierung
der Zukunft aussehen wird wenn wir die
neuen Technologien nutzen
und wie wird die Gesellschaft sich
entwickeln wenn alle einen Zugang zum
Internet
so setze sich Leonard dafür ein dass
bereits 1996 in Estland Hotspots
eingerichtet wurden zur gleichen Zeit
begann die Regierung damit die Schulen
zu digitalisieren
wir starteten in 1996 und im Jahr 2000
hatten alle estnischen Schulen Internet
und Computer
durch diese Einbindung der neuen
Technologien in den Schulen gab es eine
große Veränderung in der Gesellschaft
[Musik]
auch 23 Jahre später noch weit entfernt
in Island sind die Schulabgänger von
damals heute erwachsen und leben die
Digitalisierung mit einer elektronischen
Identität
die einzigen auf der Welt zu sein die
lächeln wenn sie ihre Steuererklärung
machen
denn es geht einfach sehr schnell
der einzige Grund warum wir uns ärgern
ist dass wir dieses Mal vielleicht zwei
Minuten anstatt einer gebraucht haben
auch wenn die Steuererklärung in
Deutschland sehr viel länger braucht es
geht zumindest digital bundesweit sind
nur durchschnittlich 21,9% der
Verwaltungsdienstleistungen online
verfügbar dabei gibt es einige
Kuriositäten in Thüringen kann man zum
Beispiel die waffenrechtliche Erlaubnis
online beantragen einen
Schwerbehindertenausweis jedoch nicht
in Hamburg kann man die Hundehaltung
digital anmelden allerdings keinen
Personalausweis beantragen ein Besuch
beim Amt dauert in Deutschland
durchschnittlich zwei einhalb Stunden
in Estland sind wir davon überzeugt dass
man seine Zeit mit besseren Dingen
verbringen kann als mit Bürokratie
mit seinen Kindern oder Hobbys
[Musik]
und so sieht die Identität aus ein
Schiff im Personalausweis enthält alle
Daten Krankenakte steuern und vieles
mehr tatsächlich kann man alle
Behördengänge Online Regeln außer
heiraten scheiden und sein Haus
verkaufen
okay theoretisch habe ich das ganze mit
der Digitalisierung in Essen verstanden
aber ich möchte es auch noch mal in der
Praxis erleben und deswegen treffe ich
mich mit Florian hartleben
[Musik]
Florian Hartlieb ist
digitalisierungsexperte und kommt
ursprünglich aus Deutschland er schreibt
Bücher zu dem Thema und lebt seit 2015
in Tallinn mit einer Essen zusammen von
hier aus berät er Politikerinnen und
Lehrerinnen zum Thema Digitalisierung
hallo ich bin Florian hallo
das geht auch von alleine okay und wir
fahren jetzt hier Bus ohne Fahrer oder
was Digitalisierung braucht eine so das
ist Vertrauen du musst eben jetzt auch
das Vertrauen haben dass wir jetzt nicht
hier in die Ecke fahren oder ins Meer
plumpsten sondern dass wir einfach hier
sagen ja wir probieren das aus
in Italien wird der digitale Fortschritt
gelebt so fahren hier auch auf einigen
ausgewählten probestrecken autonome
Busse acht Menschen haben darin Platz
und die Höchstgeschwindigkeit beträgt 12
km/h ohne Unfall erreichen wir die
Innenstadt Florian nimm mich mit in die
älteste Apotheke Europas
dabei
und sie sieht jetzt das was deine Ärztin
dir verschrieben hat okay
und jetzt kann sie das Einlesen einfach
ohne ausgedrucktes Rezept ohne gar
nichts
[Musik]
also ich merke schon so Zettelwirtschaft
wie bei uns ist hier nicht
98% der Bürger nutzen den Online-Service
Island macht es auch Startups einfach in
15 Minuten kann man ein Unternehmen
gründen das entspricht einem
kurzwaschgang
im Stadtteil ist wie kann man die
starter-badmosphäre spüren wir besuchen
einen typischen kobaltingspace
[Musik]
Florian zeigt mir hier wie man Einsicht
auf seine Daten hat und was dort alles
gespeichert ist von Pensionsansprüchen
über Elterngeld Gesundheitsdaten und
autoanmeldungen alles kann man einsehen
und nutzen
also das sind jetzt ganz schön viele
Daten tatsächlich
fühlst du dich sicher damit oder machst
du doch manchmal Gedanken es ist so dass
hier hier alles transparent ist also ich
sehe auf jeden Fall sofort dass hier
jemand zugegriffen hat der nicht
zugreifen sollte so kann man einen
Missbrauch sofort erkennen und melden
jeder Bürger entscheidet selbst wer auf
seine Daten Zugriff hat
[Musik]
das ist ja immer auch so die Frage sieht
man das Ganze immer nur von der
risikoseite ja welche Gefahren gibt es
Stichwort Datenschutz oder sehe ich das
ganze von der chancenseite und hier
glaube ich ist aus Punkt entscheidend
dass wir in Estland Digitalisierung den
Alltag vereinfacht Island traut sich und
das digitale System wächst mit dem Land
ich glaube wirklich dass am 21
Jahrhundert eine gesicherte
elektronische Identität ein
Menschenrecht sein muss
jeder und zwar jetzt
online sind und nicht irgendwann in der
Zukunft
ein spannender Tag neigt sich dem Ende
doch Estland scheint immer noch eine
Überraschung parat zu haben per App hat
Florian noch etwas bestellt
das ist jetzt hier der Roboter der ist
jetzt gerade vom Supermarkt gekommen
Florian hofft dass auch Deutschland
irgendwann den digitalen Wandel
vollzieht im Moment ist das noch schwer
vorstellbar
das waren unsere drei lieblingsideen und
klar digitaler Wandel ist auch ein
umstrittenes Thema gerade da wo es um
sensible Daten geht mit Vorsicht zu
genießen aber unsere drei visionäre
haben uns gezeigt dass Digitalisierung
auch viel Gutes mit sich bringen kann
[Musik]